the ceremony in Adis Ababa brought the
leaders of both Ethiopia and the
Breakaway territory of Somali land
closer to Long sought
goals this will be the starting point
for our cooperation with the brotherly
people of Somali land to grow and
develop together in cooperation and
ensure our common security as we've
repeatedly stated previously we don't
wish to use force on anyone rather we'll
use what we have
cooperatively the memorandum of
understanding leases Ethiopia Port
facilities on Somali land's Red Sea
Coast access to the ocean has been an
Ethiopian priority since erria became
independent three decades
ago leaving Ethiopia's remaining
territory
landlocked Somali land's President says
that in return
Ethiopia will recognize his territory's
independence Somali land declared
autonomy from the rest of Somalia in
1991 but is still claimed by
Mogadishu we are very happy and we thank
the Ethiopian Prime Minister as we
signed the agreement here we have
allowed them 20 kilm of our sea and they
will also recognize us as an independent
state they will become the first state
to recognize somal land after the
signing of this memorandum
understanding the government of Somalia
announced that it will convene an
emergency cabinet meeting to discuss the
agreement which it considers a violation
of its territorial sovereignty Alexander
buers Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer